[Music]
and prep eater I present this evergreen
and I hope will be a symbol of our
feelings for each other that we will be
constant in caring all our lives she
gave me a twig she's not another
embroider she it wasn't mentioned to my
new wife the Empress of Russia ever
since I was a child I thought like creep
nurse was in store for me no you don't
talk my love oh I got himself and spat
me past on this earth for a reason wants
to make you a woman then for comedy
I guess rabbit
there's a way of things here I'm
beginning to see that we can rule Russia
in a different way I will you serve I am
the most loved ruler in all of Russian
history don't worry about the bodies
[Music]
prisoner here married to an idiot - do
you mean to say Russia does not go to an
heir if there is not one
if the Emperor dies Russia goes to the
impressive
[Music]
do not cross me or you will pay
endlessly
there are many unhappy and we're looking
for a leader I hope I am looking at her
this is science
enjoy
you
you